all right red pill production vlog
number I lost track of the number okay
so it's just me this week Kara is off on
vacation she's out on a no Vancouver
Island or something like that so the
major things that happened this week
were we met with the construction team
who has agreed to build our set we
talked with them we had a great time
great chat they're 100 set on board
they're okay with the budget that we
were able to that we were able to offer
them we also met with the we met with
the location and we were able to sign a
deal with them and I've got a little bit
of footage here that I can show you of
what the what the location and we were
able to agree on dollar amount with them
that is it's higher than our than our
absolute preference but it's still well
below sort of our our cutoff point like
do that you know it's within budget we
just of course would have liked it to be
lower so instead of getting a good deal
we're getting a fair deal that's
probably a great way of putting it
we've got the location we've got the set
casting is going out today
later today tomorrow and that's really
about it I mean aside from that it was
it was holidays so it was super busy
early in the week of that rush to sort
of get everything done and wrapped up
before people took off for you know
vacation and whatnot and we managed to
do it and we managed to get it all all
locked down and sort of on Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and then yeah we just
kind of been kind of enjoying ourselves
since then so not a so not a long update
and I don't have care here to sort of
ramble with so that's kind of it you
know yeah so happy holidays and we'll
we'll see you in the new year
high-five